[Music]
what's up guys
we're pumpkin et today we're playing
glowing the dark ping-pong this is by
far the most requested diamond our
channel to do so we are finally doing it
we have bought a few UV lamps and then
we've got tapes we don't know if this
works at all about where you're gonna
try it out
[Music]
this is so exciting I'm really looking
forward to seeing how to look
[Music]
so we have the table ready mmm lights oh
yeah this looks wow this is way better
than I ever imagined it to be
time to give em some makeup I seriously
think the face paint is a bad idea
there we have every wall painting whoa
paint me beautiful don't pin my hair no
how much are you putting emptying the
whole bottle of my face I'll paint off
the eyebrows it looks great hey I like
those
and then something of a nose is right he
looks like a mouse I need to fool with
this looks like a cat so we're making
ourselves glow in the dark
that's so God we need more of this
sticks a bit better since my my hands
don't look like a stick figure this
looks just like a movie yeah it's way
too good to be true
if we should tape off this beard I think
we're ready to start
[Music]
[Music]
you actually can play surprisingly well
here yeah I'm surprised
[Applause]
oh goodness
[Applause]
[Music]
victory does
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
guys if you want to see more crazy
videos like this do consider hit and
subscribe
[Applause]
okay make this understood it's clearly
5:00 a.m. okay I think this is one of
the coolest things we've ever done on
our channel
yeah and if you guys enjoyed it as much
as we did remember to go and hit
subscribe also leave a like if you want
to see part two until next time